The National Institutes of Health Clinical and translational science awards program CTSA,
seeks to facilitate that translation of research into clinical practice.
Harvard Medical School has created SHRIN,
the shared health research informatics network.
A web based software network,
SHRIN links the respective I2B2 instances of five of
Harvard's CTSA partner hospitals for the sharing of aggregated counts of patients.
Meaning selected inclusion and exclusion criteria for demographics,
diagnoses, medications and lab tests.
The goal is for SHRIN to enable population based research,
assessment of potential clinical trial cohorts and
hypothesis formation for follow up study by combining the H.R.
assets across the hospital systems.
The department of biomedical informatics at
Harvard Medical School is working with health care centers across the
U.S. to develop the scalable collaborative infrastructure for
learning health system S C I L H S, pronounced Schils.
Each site will install a software suite comprised of
I2B2 creating a federated query and response system using SHRIN,
the smart platform, the Indivio PHR and
the redcap research electronic data capture tool used to survey patients online.